guys i can already see all your comments
coming in
and let me know which country are you
from as well i can see
some of you are from india um south
africa
oh my gosh south africa i know it's
super early in the morning
welcome so let me know which country
you're from
and really just leave your questions in
regards to your health and fitness
okay right i am so excited because
i will also be having a guest
in my session today okay and for today's
session i will be joined by a very
special guest
okay are we ready keep your questions
coming okay
so today's live chat is in partnership
with circuit dna
some of you might have heard of circuit
dna through my youtube videos
and i know that a lot of you have
questions in regards to
your dna insights and how it relates to
your health and fitness journey and
that's exactly what we will be answering
today all right
and for those of you some of you might
have done your dna testing with circuit
dna as well
for those of you who have not done your
circuit dna testing
be sure to hop onto their website circle
dna.com
and use the promo code joanna to get one
kid for 35
off two to three kids for 40 off
and four or more kids for 50
off and here's the best part
just for today's live stream all of you
who are watching
those on facebook hop on to youtube
right now just for today's
live stream i will be giving away five
premium circle dna kit
and also free three month field
membership which is worth 650 dollars
okay
this kit will really help you in
understanding your health and fitness
journey
so you don't want to be missing out on
this chance and the winners will be
announced at the end of
this session all right so how to win
basically by engaging in today's session
the more you engage
the more you ask relevant questions the
higher your chances of winning so
keep commenting keep typing away because
i will be selecting some of the
questions and i will be asking
them as well so guys i am so excited
and a lot of you might be wondering what
is dna testing
yeah why is dna testing so important why
is it so important to understand
more about my genetics well your gene
makes up who you are basically you are
you know
your gene basically makes up who you are
and that's something we are born with
that's something we can't change so by
understanding your genetics
you will stop guessing and you will know
exactly
what to do in order to optimize your
health
your nutrition and also your training
program
okay so for instance some of you might
be curious why
does my body respond this way to a
certain kind of food
and why am i intolerant to this or
why am i training and i'm really
training really hard but i'm not losing
the weight
that's when your dna testing comes
comes to play a really important role
and that's what that we will be speaking
on today and you might be curious how do
i then get my dna testing done okay so
basically once you purchase
the circa dna premium kit this
this right here will be sent to you okay
and so let's unbox this all right
and you will get the dna collection kit
all you have to do it's really really
simple
all you have to do is a simple cheek
swap all right
and i'm going to show you how to do it
right now so open it
and what i want to make sure is that
avoid
eating drinking or smoking
at least 30 minutes before you get your
test done
so what we want to do now is basically
swap
about 10 times okay i'm gonna actually
do it
on one side of the cheek and about
another 10 times
on the other side and once that's done
all you have to do is open this tube
this tube right here
okay place it in
all right break it
got it close it
and this is how the test is done okay
and now just give it a good
shake all right so mix it really well
give it a good shake
and all you have to do is ship this
back to them and after four weeks
you will receive your dna result in
the mobile app so it's really simple and
you get over
500 reports as you can see on the box
it covers diet nutrition stress and
sleep
cancer risks family planning
and more it's a really comprehensive
test over 500 reports
and all you have to do is one test
for a lifetime because guys your dna
test
your dna your genetics will not change
okay so it is
that simple all right so now that i've
shown you
how to do the test you've gotten the
test done
the next step is you will also receive a
free consultation
with their health coaches and i did my
consultation
with one of their health coaches called
xin ping and
today she will be our special guest she
will be sharing with us more about
getting fit
and also losing weight by understanding
your dna
insights so this is your chance to
really pour in the questions
ask any questions you might have because
champing will also be answering them
okay are we i'm so excited to have one
on board
let's welcome champing to today's chat
everyone hi champing
how are you how are you doing i'm good
how are you
i am really excited to i mean to be
hosting today's live stream with you
because i had my consultation with you
and you have shed so much of you know
valuable information which i've taken on
board and pretty much
adjusted and changed my diet tweaks
small tweaks here and there
in regards to my diets and also training
and it has helped me a lot
so i think a lot of viewers are really
excited because they have so many
burning questions right now but before
we get started okay
can you share more with my viewers about
what you do with circle dna tests
i mean circuit dna okay sure so hi
everyone
my name is champing i am a health coach
from circa dna
so i am a nutritionist with a master's
in nutrition
and with a background in biotechnology
so ever since graduation i've been
working as a health coach doing talks
and workshops in different settings
so basically i've dedicated my life to
helping people take better care of
themselves
so i'm really excited to be joining
joanna today
uh in this qnn session so hopefully
we'll be able to
answer some of your burning questions
about dna testing and how they relate to
health
and you know your weight management yeah
okay
all right cool right um yes i mean
i mean i've posted and i mean i've
posted on my
facebook and instagram page and you know
i wanted to get
my viewers to start commenting and start
asking some of the questions they
might have and i think one of the most
common questions that people tend to ask
is that
will my dna result change if i change my
lifestyle
that's something really common yeah okay
that's a really good question i think
that's a really good question to start
us off in our session today
um so the dna that we have um
we actually get it from our parents so
one set from our mother and one set from
our father
and so over time this would not change
um
but even so our lifestyle our
environment
everything like that would still change
and they would still affect our risk or
probability of getting certain
conditions or developing certain traits
yeah so
uh what you know knowing your genetics
is it's just
going to be a very useful tool to tweak
like you said
your current lifestyle just to kind of
move things along the right direction
yeah yeah i think something that i mean
uh people have to realize
is that your genetics is not a life
sentence i mean the truth is that
some of us are blessed with better genes
and some of us are unfortunately
not blessed with you know um maybe such
great of opportunity
but that doesn't mean that it's a life
sentence because
your lifestyle is extremely important
how you live your life is even more
important in determining how
your health will be in the future am i
right to say that
yes exactly so so that's why
you know we we make it a point to really
engage with
our clients and understand their current
lifestyle and we pair it together with
their genetic profile
to give them very personalized you know
recommendations and advice
and things like that yeah okay okay and
another common question that
you know i get asked so often
i'm sure you get asked extremely often
as well is you know why am i not losing
weight
even though i'm eating healthy i am
sleep
i'm eating healthy and i'm exercising
very consistently
why am i not losing weight i've tried
every source of diet out there
what am i doing wrong and what would
your answer be
uh okay so first of all we really do
understand that the frustration that
comes with that
when you you feel like you're doing
everything right and i think it's
happening
and i would say yes your diet and your
exercise
it's really important for you know
making sure that your health is you know
in the right condition
that you are helping your body lose the
extra weight that it's carrying around
but there are other things that we don't
really associate as much
so things like our sleep and stress um
they are very important because they
will affect our metabolism our health
so for example if we don't sleep very
well and we are under
stress you know for most of the time so
what would happen is that your body
would produce
a bit more of the stress hormones that
would then cause you to feel you know
hungrier
uh you crave more high fat high sugar
foods
and in certain people it could also mean
that maybe you would store a bit more
fat around the belly the tummy area
yeah so that's why you know sleep and
stress those are actually very important
uh aspects of you know weight management
and health as well but perhaps
it's not as well talked about so you
know
correct i mean i totally agree with that
i mean that's something that i always
emphasize
um on my youtube channel is yes
exercising is extremely important
your diet is extremely important but a
third important component that people
tend to overlook
because of their hectic lifestyle their
busy lifestyle is their sleep
you know they they might not be getting
enough sleep or maybe their stress level
is extremely high
and when your hormone is imbalanced it
will
and can lead to weight gain or it can
prevent you from
losing the weight that you want so i
think that's something that that needs
to be um that
that needs to have more emphasis on okay
so we're going to get
into some questions that we have from
our our viewers right now
all right kay is asking hi joanna i just
wanted to know how
reliable is dna testing with respect
to weight loss and health if a test
shows that i should avoid a certain food
does it mean that i shouldn't have it at
all what does it mean
okay um so in terms of whether or not
it's
reliable so well there are many ways to
test whether it's reliable right so
i'll just give you an example so if our
test okay in our
diet report we actually test for
sensitivities towards
you know carbs and fats and if you have
you know higher sensitivity towards cups
it doesn't mean that you cannot have
cups or if you have higher sensitivity
towards
fats then it doesn't mean that you
cannot have fats but you just want to be
a bit more cautious
uh with the type and the portion signs
of the foods that you do
take yeah so um so so that's kind of
like the over
uh overfill the general idea okay so
but so basically it's not telling you
that the test is not telling you that oh
no you can't have this you can't do this
it's not restricting you but rather it's
educating you
to let you know what maybe your body
will need more of and maybe something
that you might
um reduce or eat less in your diet
exactly yeah yeah okay all right
i think i think that's very helpful i
think i mean one thing that i always
believe in is it's not about restriction
it's about finding the right balance and
it's about
knowledge information having the
knowledge having the information
will help you to lead a healthy
lifestyle not just now
but for long term because once you're
well educated
you know exactly what to do for your
body so i don't like it when someone
tells me
what you shouldn't do and what you
should do and i don't tell that to my
viewers as well because i think that's a
very
um easy approach that is not sustainable
yes yeah okay another question
another question i'm from janae lee
actor for my 70 year old mom after
eating and drinking so long
will the test still reflect accurately
to clarify
this test should not be used like a
medical checkup and it is less accurate
for older people
yeah okay i think yeah all right
so definitely the dna test is not a
medical test so it cannot replace you
know your blood test
or your annual checkup at the doctors
uh it's really to look at your genetics
so like we mentioned just now your
genetics are not going to change
throughout your lifetime so whether you
know you are a bit younger
like you know your 20s or 30s or if
you're in your 60s
or 70s like your mom then um it really
doesn't matter because your genes are
still going to be the same
so you can still uh do the tests yeah so
okay
all right and okay i'm going to move on
some of the previous questions that i
have from my viewers
something that i know i struggle with as
well okay
um and for those of you who have just
tuned in for those of you who are
probably
probably on facebook who have just tuned
in as well
guys i am giving away up to five premium
circle dna kits just for today's live
stream okay
and this kit is worth 629
so how to win basically i want you to
keep engaging
keep asking questions throughout the
live chat
any questions in relation to weight loss
and also getting fit by understanding
your dna insights and you will stand a
chance to win
this circle dna premium kit where
you will get over 500 reports
on your nutrition training sleep and
stress
cancer risks family planning and also
diseases
so this is your chance to win this right
here okay
all right so getting back to the
questions
this next question is something that i
struggle with as well and
my dna test actually says that i have
low appetite control okay
so i know i have low appetite control um
one of the viewers asked i struggle to
control my food cravings especially when
i'm stressed out
how can i control it when my dna test
results
says that i have low appetite control
yeah
because i know i go crazy as well
okay good question uh so our appetite is
actually
controlled or affected by you know
different factors so one of it is
genetics
so for example if your test results tell
you that genetically you have a lower
appetite control
then you know that could mean that you
uh don't feel
as satisfied with your meals and you
tend to get a bit hungrier
even you know after having a meal so
that's where it's really important to
still
have very balanced meals healthy and
balanced meals
with you know healthy carbs healthy fats
and a bit of lean proteins
all this would really affect how
satisfied you feel with your meals you
know
even though you are trying to cut down
you're trying to lose weight but we
always
recommend not cutting out you know
things completely certain food goods
completely
because what will happen you know you
feel very hungry and very dissatisfied
with your meals afterwards
and then you will start thinking okay
maybe i want to have a bit of snack here
and then and some people
it leads to binge eating and it becomes
a vicious cycle you know
yeah yeah it's it's really that's why we
always advocate for a very balanced
approach
so that's you know if you genetically
you have this problem so some people
they also you know get a bit of a higher
appetite
a bigger appetite when they are stressed
out you know going through something
very difficult
and that is also something that we
empathize with we all you know have gone
through this
and for people who are prone to
emotional eating
i think it's really important to
identify the triggers that
causes you to eat or causes you to snack
whenever you are like stressed out or
you're very
nervous or things like that yeah so and
once you identify that trigger
then you'll be able to replace those you
know unhealthy habits with things that
may be a bit better for you so things
like okay yoga
yeah just on top of my head right now i
i mean this is based on my own
experience okay do not
use your um low appetite control genetic
results as an excuse all right yeah
i mean i mean i i know it because i i
have the same results but
i really believe that it's not about
restriction it's about
building the right positive habits and
it's so important to build positive
habits because
habit is something you do on a daily
basis so if every time you're stressed
out
you start to binge that's the habit that
you're building and that's not going to
be healthy long term so it's important
to start building positive habits
um even at home and even from a young
age as well and something that i
practice
is that because i know um i struggle to
control my portion if i
if i have something i want more of it
what i tend to do is
to not store junk foods at home so
so you know when i'm stressed out or
when i'm hungry or tired
there's nothing unhealthy for me to
snack on at home so i will turn to
more healthier alternatives and i will
let's say i enjoy my occasional treats
of
ice creams you know cakes and things
like that with my friends
so it's more of a social thing rather
than a coping mechanism
so that's one tip to really um avoid
snacking on junks because you when you
don't have junks at home
chances are you will you will turn to um
you will pick up another habit
to do perhaps it can be drinking tea to
cope with your stress
so i think that's something that that
really helps me
okay right um a similar question that i
have from our previous viewer and also
a viewer that's just asking jen aviro
does dna have an effect on metabolism
and can that be changed because i know
that
based on the dna tests that you do with
circular dna they will also let you know
which category you fall under is it high
metabolism is it low metabolism
and honestly some people blame it on
their metabolism because they have low
metabolism therefore they are not losing
weight
so what is your advice on that okay
uh so yes we do get this question quite
a bit as well
uh so our metabolism is is really
affected by a lot of factors as well
uh so things like genetics so for
example if your test tells you that you
have a lower metabolic rate
so they are things that we can do to
maybe you know boost or increase your
metabolic rate so one of it is really to
do with uh exercising so doing the right
kind of exercise so things like strength
training you know weight training
all this that are gonna help you build
up your muscles
these are all gonna help you increase
your metabolic rate uh that's one thing
the other thing is also your diet so
making sure that you have
you know sufficient amount of protein
with each meal
uh that's also gonna help you know
maintain or boost your metabolic rate
so the other thing would be uh like what
we mentioned just now the stress and
sleep part so not sleeping enough
is also gonna be very bad for a
metabolic rate yeah so these are a few
things that we really wanna pay
attention to when we talk about
metabolism yeah i think um
for me i i definitely agree with that
at the end of the day we it comes down
to you know your nutrition and your
your training as well and i think one
thing great about the result is that not
only do you get the result
but there are also recommendations
within the app
to let you know what you should do more
of and
the recommendations on the food intake
and food groups as well so that's
something i find really
useful within the circle dna app is that
they do provide recommendations as well
so it's not just um your results but it
comes with recommendations as well
okay lots of questions pouring in guys
i am going to try my best you know to go
through as
many questions as i can all right okay
and the next question from kurt papilla
forgive me if i'm getting your names
wrong what are the indicators
we should look out for from the test
that would signify that we now need to
seek external help
like from doctors or does it have to
or does it have like a build up in
feature already that reminds
us so basically based on the test
results are there any
things that would let us know if we
should get external help
from the doctors um okay
so because you know like like joanna you
have shared right there are so many
different
uh parts in the test so there are things
like this risk or cancerous
so if you are concerned about that it's
always a good idea to
to speak to your doctor to speak to a gp
about it there is no
built-in reminder that that kind of
pings you and say oh you should see the
doctor right away
uh but in terms of uh when you do speak
with the coaches so you
when you speak to us or the genetic
counselors then
uh we would help you know highlight
certain things that you maybe want to
pay a bit more attention to
then based on our conversation then
maybe we'll just tell you okay
so maybe uh you might want to pay a bit
more attention here
and you might want to you know make sure
you do your regular health checkouts and
speak to your doctor about this specific
area
yeah so that's the general idea
okay okay and the next question is from
melvin wong
if we already it comes back to same
thing diseases and a pre-existing health
condition
if we already have pre-existing
conditions like diabetes and chronic
diseases
can the test help give me more insights
on this
yeah so for someone who has perhaps lead
already leading
a not very healthy lifestyle and they
already have these conditions
will the dna test then help them further
yeah so definitely uh so the dna test is
not just for people who are healthy or
for people who are unhealthy it's really
for everyone because everyone will get
certain values from it so for example
right now if you are already having
certain chronic conditions and you
really want to know okay you are on this
diet and you're on this exercise regime
but you want to know okay based on my
genes can i still further tweak it so
that it's a bit more appropriate for me
it's a bit more useful for me so for
example if you are diabetic
and you your report tells you that you
have a higher sensitivity towards cuts
then you you would know okay it's even
more important for you
to be really careful with your cup
intake and work with your dietitian your
doctor to
to really you know uh make sure that you
are taking the best care of yourself
that you possibly can
yeah okay all right okay okay so
um let's get back to some of the
questions that
i already had um what if my dna results
this is more in relation to training
let's move a little bit into training
right now okay
what if my dna results says that my
sports profile is high endurance but
i want to build all my strength so
what would your answer be because let me
just give a brief summary on the results
basically for your sports profile there
will be three categories
so you have the endurance power and
strength
so your genetic will be a mixture of
all three so for example my results okay
my result says that i have high
endurance
medium power and low strength so that's
my genetic
profile for others it could be um high
strength
medium power and low endurance so it's
different based on individuals
so for this lady right here her sports
profile is high endurance
but she wants to build on a strength so
does it mean she should focus more on
endurance training and just
add a little bit of strength training or
should you focus more on
building her strength okay
so thanks for the you know overview i
think that's a really useful thing
for our viewers to know so for
um this customer with a high endurance
profile so what this means is that
she will likely respond better to
endurance-based exercises so things like
walking running swimming
cycling that sort of thing yeah but it
doesn't mean that she shouldn't do any
strength
based or strength increasing exercises
like weight training
uh it just means that you know she can
use the genetic profile
to tweak how she does her strength
training so in her case high endurance
perhaps she when she's doing her weight
training for example
then she can maybe do it in a more low
intensity way
so in terms of weight training it will
be things like you know using low loads
and using a higher repetitions just to
kind of you know work
the muscles so that would be something
that she can do and also she can
you know break up her workouts to to be
a bit more endurance based
at a bit lower in intensity rather than
very very high intensity that
you know a lot of people think you must
do to get results
yeah okay yeah and and
yeah and i agree with that as well
because for me
my endurance is i have high endurance
and i have
low strength believe it or not okay
and that's something that you know i
always struggle with in the gym because
honestly i i love gym workouts i love
strength training
but i would say that whenever i see
other ladies lifting heavier than me
i would be like you know what i will
never be lifting as heavy as them
and i come to realize that there is no
point competing or trying to be like
them
because my body type is not like them my
strength is
endurance but that also doesn't mean
that i should only be doing steady pace
running
what i can do is still perform strength
training
but adapt it and and and really utilize
my endurance side
so basically instead of performing heavy
weights all the time
what i'll do is i'll have maybe two
heavy weights
extremely heavy weight session a week
and then i will mix it with
three medium weight but higher reps
so that's how i would do it and honestly
for the past one year
that's how i've been training and it has
really helped me
so yeah so it's not that you should or
you
you should avoid strength training or
avoid endurance training or power
if your results show that you are low
but it's about making those small tweaks
that will benefit your body type so
that's something that um i've learned
yeah and okay lots of questions coming
in i am
trying my best to keep up okay
okay hang on
right let's see
um i'm uh okay the next question is from
t jens i'm a mum with three
young kids can this test let me know
what my children is good at
for example um tests shows high power
or it doesn't okay or does it mean that
it should be weight lifting that he
excels in
uh okay so if you do tests for
um if you do the genetic testing or the
dna testing for you and your family
and for your kids and your kids would
have you know different profiles of
course
a combination of your profile and your
husband's profile and if it says you
know high strength and high
uh power so it goes back to what we just
talked about you know it doesn't mean
that you
shouldn't do like delay or should do
swimming or because
there's also another component to
exercise where you really want to do
something that you enjoy
because that's something that's gonna
stick right um so it just means that you
know
if you're high endurance you will
respond better and if you are
high strength then you will respond
better to certain things like weight
training yeah so it really depends on
the lifestyle the interest that sort of
thing as well
okay okay and and okay before we move on
to
you know more more and more questions i
mean guys i'm loving this keep engaging
keep asking your question okay
um for those of you who have just tuned
in again i'm just going to remind you
engage in today's live stream because
you will stand a chance to win
the circle dna premium kit and this kit
is worth
629 and on top of that i will also be
giving away
three month premium fuel membership okay
so in total
it's worth 650 dollars this
circle dna premium kit will provide you
with more than
500 reports in relation to your health
fitness cancer risks sports profile
sleep and stress everything you need to
know in regards to your body
so i will be giving this away up to
five premium kids so leave your comments
keep commenting and you will stand a
chance to win this at the end of the
session
so be sure to stay tuned throughout the
entire session okay
all right okay the next question i think
is really interesting
it's from evgel santos
does your ethnicity also contribute to
the kind of diet a person
should do i think this is really
interesting
okay so in our dna testing we do have a
section where we test for ancestries
um and there are certain research that
are showing us that you know certain
type of people certain ethnicities they
would have you know certain
mutations of certain genes that would
predispose or increase their risk for
certain conditions for example uh so of
course these are the things that
you can take into consideration uh
but right now we don't um segregate
it or we don't make it a very very clear
point where we say oh because you are
this
uh ethnic part of this ethnic group then
you have a higher risk of this yeah but
there's definitely a
a relationship between this okay okay
yeah i think i think one of the more
obvious
result in the dna test is actually
lactose intolerant
because i think we we know that 90 to 95
of asians are lactose intolerant so that
is very
prominent in the result compared to
let's say someone from the western
country
so yeah so that's in a way it's it's
based on your ethnicity as well
yeah we don't you just don't tell you oh
it's because of your ex yeah
totally totally get it okay um the next
question which i think will be really
useful
for all of us is can i continue eating
the same diet
let's say if i were in my 40s or 30s
compared to let's say if i get older
once i hit my 50 and 60s
or should i adjust my diet and food
portion
as i get older what is your
recommendation for that
okay um so whenever we get this kind of
question i think it's really important
to really look at
right now what sort of diet are you
having because
if right now you are having a very um
unhealthy
diet that consists of like fast foods or
all this you know processed foods
then you definitely want to be really
cautious about it
especially as you get older because
things like our metabolism
the the functioning in the body may
start going down a little bit
but if right now you are following a
very healthy diet then of course then
you can still continue because
it's a lifestyle right it's not really
like a specific diet
that you have to follow very
restrictively very strictly
uh so it really depends on your current
lifestyle and
you know whether or not you want to
tweak it as you grow older
yeah yeah i think i think i think these
questions
get asked often is that because you know
when we're in our 20s
no matter what you eat even if you don't
work out
you still have that flat abs you know
you will still have that toned arms
you will still look good correct but
yeah once you hit your thirties once you
hit your fault it's like oh my god why
am i getting that valley pooch
why am i gaining weight although i'm
still eating the same amount of food
and i think people fail to realize that
your metabolism starts to slow down as
you get older
and you ten you start to lose muscle
mass as well as you get older
and that is why training exercising is
extremely important
from a young age even if you don't train
even if you don't exercise from a young
age
you can still do it as you get older
because it will help you to maintain
your muscle mass
it will help you to boost your
metabolism and to keep you
looking good so a lot of the times
people fail to understand that
you know just like any older engines it
will start to slow down
it will start to you know um it will
start to slow down therefore you need to
put that extra effort
to maintain it yeah
that's that's a that's a good question i
find that question really
really useful yeah okay
all right next question
um all right someone wants to know
cakey crafts all right cakey crafts can
you tell us more in details about the
cancer risks
from the test yeah i think i want to
know this as well because
based on my results i have um three
three cancer risks i think so what does
it mean
uh okay so with uh the cancer risk
that you have in the report um so we
what we are testing for is uh we are
testing for
well-known genes associated with certain
types of cancers
yeah so if you do find that you have
higher risk for that and you have a
family history of having cancer and that
sort of thing
then the genetic counselor will also
bring you through your cancer risk
profile and talk you through what this
actually means
and they will also give you
recommendations on you know
whether or not you want to do early
screening for certain things uh
just to make sure that you can catch
things early and
you know get the appropriate treatments
yeah
okay okay all right yeah so it's not
telling you what you have or what you
no no no yeah yeah yeah yeah i think
yeah yeah it's not a medical no no no
it's basically telling um it's basically
asking you to just pay more attention to
it
yeah so i think that sets a useful
information and again your genetics will
not change so that's a really useful
information for you to have
um and to just pay more attention just
be more aware again it's information
giving you information having
information you will be more aware
okay right right let's let's go back to
um for those of you who are who are on
facebook right now be sure to hop onto
my youtube channel
and ask your questions okay and i will
be able to answer them on youtube
right let's let's keep going through the
questions
okay
right um the next one is from
jackie cakes i love the you i mean the
usernames you guys use on youtube
seriously
jackie cakes and like you know something
else okay
right jackie takes i have two siblings
that
are women too the three of us so three
females
all siblings have different body type
all right
so i'm assuming one is like slimmer one
is like in the middle and one is
probably on
on the more curvier side and i
ex joe as joanna explained in one of her
videos
since we have one set of parents
does the dna show our different
metabolism how does it work then because
same parents three totally different
body types
how does that work okay uh very good
question
and um i also have you know uh
it's just three of us girls so two
sisters as well
so i understand where everyone can be
very different right even though we have
the sense of uh
set of parents and okay so remember
where we talked about you know where we
get our dna from we get it from our mom
and our dad but we don't get this
exactly the same
combination of the dna because if we do
then we'll all look the same and be the
same right but
even so if we get different combinations
that's why we
some some uh perhaps you uh for example
me i would have
one set of dna results but my sister
could have you know something that is
slightly different yeah so that would
also
be one of the reasons and the other
thing is really our lifestyle and our
environment
is also a really big thing so our diet
how how we exercise
you know even twins even though they
have you know the same
uh very very similar dna but they can
still look very different or
have very different disease risk based
on their lifestyle yeah so it's entirely
possible
different combinations okay okay all
right that's that's something that yeah
that's something interesting so don't be
jealous of your sisters
be grateful for your body okay that's
something that i always emphasize oh
we're not factory you know we're not
made from the factory we will look
different and that's something that we
should all embrace
all right different bodies you know but
still equally
just as beautiful okay and
right i that's another really
interesting question
this is coming from chloe garcia
hi joanna there are studies that show
how our mental health
can be genetic um can we also get
insights on this from the dna result
mental health plays a big role on our
motivation especially in exercise and
yes there are actually a lot of studies
out there showing that your mental
health
actually um is also related to your
genetics so
how can the dna results help the viewers
okay uh so yes i i do think that mental
health
is a really important component to our
health not just physical
or emotional health right mental health
is also something that we really need to
speak a bit more
talk a bit more about and in our dna
test we do have a section on sleep and
stress management
that has something to do with uh mental
health as well so how well you cope with
stress
whether or not you are at higher risk
for stress induced obesity for example
yeah so there are some components to
this and
hope we are what we are hoping is that
in the future we will
uh continue adding you know more and
more tests as the results get a bit
more you know concrete and we can uh
just start adding them in yeah
so based on that you can also uh
really talk about you know how well you
can deal with stress or whether or not
you need to be a bit more cautious with
certain things yeah
definitely okay all right okay um okay
okay the next question from i'm never
gonna try to say your username
my my nch9 okay jonah since you have
used your dna testing
in your fitness can you give us the
differences in your fitness journey when
you did not have the test
yet compared to after you had your dna
test okay so this is for me to answer
okay right so um for those of you who
have just tuned in basically we're
talking about circle dna test
test today and i did my test
about one one and a half years ago now
so it was towards
the end of 2019 and before that
before that i was pretty much just you
know the funny thing is that i've always
been eating a healthy balanced diet and
when i got my results
my diet recommendation was also healthy
balance
so let me just sort of like break it
down for you in
the test result there are four
categories under nutrition
so there's healthy balance there is low
fat there is low
carbs and there is mediterranean so my
result falls under healthy balance
so when it comes to my nutrition
i realize that you know what healthy
balance actually suits
me but when i dive deeper into the
results then the results showed me
certain vitamins that i might be lacking
so then that's how i started adding more
of those nutritions into my diet such as
you know i'm on a i'm
on a predominantly um i would say
pescatarian diet
so um i've added more um fish into my
diet i've added more
uh healthy oils like nuts and seeds and
it has really helped with my digestion
i think something that if you have been
watching me and following me on youtube
you will know that i i always have
digestive issues okay
uh always feel bloated always feel super
uncomfortable
any little changes to my diet were
really i would really struggle it would
really affect my digestion
so since having the results since
knowing what i need more of
and what i should not consume as much it
has really helped me
and when it comes to my sports profile
again before that
it was just me training as how i like it
you know i would do my hit workouts i
would do my strength training in the gym
pretty much just training how i like and
how i feel and honestly i did enjoy my
training i'm not gonna say that i didn't
enjoy my training
but it was just um training like
like how everybody else would to a
certain extent but once i got my results
that's when i realized that
um i'm high endurance i have medium
power and i have low strength and it
also makes total sense because
a lot of you have been always asking me
how can you just film your videos
talk you know jump around and still talk
and still film
i think besides coming down to practice
it has a lot to do with my endurance um
ability and also you know my power
ability
and something that i i know i have to
put extra work into is my strength
it's not easy for me to build my
strength it's not easy for me to even
build let's say muscles for some people
who have high strength
they for them their body type it's much
easier for them to build muscles and
muscle mass and strength for me
that's something that i have to put in
more effort and focus on more so
that's how i've in a way adjusted my
training by focusing a little bit more
on strength
and also same thing to still incorporate
power and endurance
and really leverage on that as my um as
my
as my basically based on my genetic
profile so
that's how i find it being really useful
and i hope my sharing today is helping
you as well
okay um just like this we are already 45
minutes into our
session okay so guys you have about
10 minutes left okay 10 minutes left for
you to ask your questions
keep engaging again i'm gonna repeat
myself because i think
today's giveaway is pretty damn amazing
i mean you get to win this circle circle
dna kit
okay this premium testing kit which is
worth 629 dollars
and also free three-month fuel
membership so in total you're winning
650 dollars
just by joining in today's live stream
and engaging for those of you on
facebook
quickly hop onto youtube ask your
questions on youtube and you will stand
a chance to win this as well okay
10 minutes left i will be announcing the
winner at the end of
this live session so keep engaging
and let me get back to your questions
right now right guys
again let me know okay if you find this
live stream to be extremely useful
extremely um let's say helpful and you
want more live stream in the future
let me know in the comments as well
because i think this is the best way for
me to interact with you as well
and we really get to ask all the
questions that you have
in regards to health and fitness okay
right and i am giving away
five kids okay it has been decided i'm
giving away
five five lucky winners i know champing
is like
what
this thing has really helped me all
right
okay more questions
okay i'm scrolling through i'm like
trying to keep up okay
right hang on
okay all right i think i really want to
touch on this because i think it's
interesting
and something we uh people often ask as
well ling
chan i am exploring for keto diet
and how can the dna report give me
advice
if keto is good for me or not
and are there any diet or exercise
recommendations to reduce weight
yeah i think champagne you have to
answer this
okay lots of information yeah yeah um so
yes the keto diet has been a very
popular thing you know in the media and
everything
and whether or not we are suited to keto
it's again comes back to whether or not
you are sensitive to
fats for example so i do uh i have
spoken to many of my clients who
have tried keto in the past and they
keep telling me
but i don't feel like i'm losing weight
and i feel like i'm actually gaining
weight on keto
and they're asking me why and once we
look at their diet uh
profile together then they realize hey
actually i'm i have higher
towards fats so what that means is that
your body might absorb a bit more fat
the
rate of absorption is a bit higher for
you in terms of fat so perhaps the keto
diet is not the best thing for you even
though everyone keeps
you know raving about it saying it's
very good and that sort of thing
yeah so that's what the dna report is
there to do it's to really give you that
kind of information
then uh i will talk to you about you
know what sort of uh diet
and exercise would be better for you
based on your profile
yeah yeah i think i think i mean i i
have to agree with you you know
i think one of the you know what being
in this industry for such an in in such
a long time for such a long time
i'm losing my words right now but it
really frustrates me
to see that people are always following
the latest diet trend
out there and you know what someone can
just shift from being low carb to high
protein to keto you know within a month
because to them they just hope for this
miraculous solution they just hope for
this medical diet that will work for
them
and i think the first thing that we have
to understand is that it takes time for
your body to adapt first of all to a
diet no matter what diet
you choose to follow it takes time for
your body to adapt
so you can't just expect magical
american solution
by following a diet for let's say three
weeks uh three days or one week and then
change
it doesn't work that way and the second
thing that we have to realize is that
our body is different so a lot of you
tend to ask me am i on a low-carb diet
my honest answer is no okay no
i'm asian i eat rice every single day
believe it or not i do eat rice every
single day
in at least two meals my lunch and
dinner so that's why i've also
you know did videos on eating rice on my
youtube channel because
i don't think we should categorize a
food group
as bad but rather it's about knowing how
to find
the right balance and also knowing how
to eat according to your body type
so for me my body tolerates carbs my
body tolerates
fats as well hence i can practice a
healthy balanced diet but
everything in the right portion in
moderation for those of you if you have
done your test
and it says that you know what your body
doesn't tolerate cups as well
so that's when that that's when it
doesn't mean that you have to remove
carb
it just means that you have to eliminate
the unhealthy processed
carbs and introduce more um real
food and and unprocessed cups same thing
goes with
if your results show that you are into
your body doesn't tolerate fat as well
again it doesn't mean that
you should avoid all the healthy fats
what it means is that you should reduce
the saturated fat and consume more
unsaturated fats
so i think information again knowledge
is power but understanding
your body it's for you to take charge
and be in control of your
own diet and it according how it suits
you
not according to the trends out there
because trends are just trends
and one year down the road there will be
another trend
okay okay all right
just following up on that okay champagne
um a question from june
we what do you mean by sensitive to
certain foods
do you mean allergies or yeah what do
you mean by sensitive
okay so sensitivity can mean different
things for different foods
so in our diet report for example we
tell you you are sensitive towards carbs
fats
uh alcohol uh salt for example
so there are so many different types of
sensitivities and each of them can mean
different things
so that's why having the complimentary
coaching session with us is going to be
useful for you because
you're not just getting like a blank a
piece of paper that tells you okay
you're sensitive towards
this but we'll actually explain and take
you through what it means to be
sensitive towards carbs what it means to
be sensitive towards
alcohol yeah so there's no one-size-fit
or answer to what it means to be
sensitive to something because it means
different okay
yeah and i think um the great thing is
that once you've gotten your result you
will also get a health consultation
with either champion either champion or
someone else but
in that health consultation will really
give you a deeper insight and free
a chance for you to ask any questions
you have and it's very specific to your
results
so that's the beauty about it it's
specific to your results only
all right we only have five minutes left
okay
so one final question and for those of
you who
are asking all the questions and i
didn't manage to answer um don't worry
i will try my best to get back to you um
on on the video itself
and again i will also reply you
on my youtube videos okay so keep asking
and keep pouring in your questions
okay the final question is from
this um is in relation to training
trisha wong hi joanna does that mean
that we can train however
we prefer whether it's hit or strength
training
as long as we have the energy and power
yeah so yeah i think i think people are
still a little bit confused on how they
can
structure their workouts um maybe
champion you can share more about uh
more on that
according to their results sure yeah
so uh okay so how you structure your
workouts
yes you can structure it based on your
genetic profile so
for example if you have high strength
profile
then and you work out five days a week
okay then what you could do
is you could do three days of strength
based exercise
one day of power based exercise and one
day of endurance exercise
yeah so that could be you know a clearer
way to kind of
help you structure your training program
yeah
and whether or not you want to do
specific types of exercise
again it really depends on your
lifestyle whether or not you enjoy that
specific
exercise yeah i would say if you're
trying to train for a certain
uh health goal then tailoring it to your
genetic profile that's
really the best way to go yeah and still
making sure that you enjoy it
yeah yeah i mean a good example we would
be myself okay i
am high endurance uh but honestly
i don't like skinny days running i mean
i know i can run if i force myself to
run i know i can do it
but i don't enjoy it so i'm not gonna do
it you know because it doesn't mean that
i have to force myself to do it
but i can always um leverage on my
endurance strength
by tweaking my strength training a
method
and do more high reps and lower weights
so
it's not a matter of getting so fixed on
a certain spot
but how you can manipulate your training
method i think that's something that
yeah i think that's something that we
have to understand all right
okay fine one one last question okay
so many questions i can't miss all the
good questions okay
this has got to do with sleep it comes
from again k
does dna influence our sleep patterns
and reactions to stress
and since our dna can't change what can
we do
okay so yes very good um
i think we've touched briefly on this in
the previous questions but yes there is
a section on sleep and stress management
in in your dna report and it will tell
you whether you're a light sleeper
you are likely to sleep easily that sort
of thing yeah so based on that results
then you can actually uh we will work
with you again
based on your current lifestyle what has
been bothering you
and we will give you some
recommendations for better sleep so for
example sleep hygiene and all that which
i think uh generally we could all
benefit from you know maybe not looking
at our phone before
we sleep that sort of thing but yes
there is a genetic component to sleep
and stress
and there is insights ah there are
insights in the
report for you yeah i think you know i
was smiling when you were i'm giving
your answers just now it's because
my sleep report shows that i'm a deep
sleeper which is totally true
i can knock off like literally
um you know when i'm on my bed i will
sleep in less than five minutes
and i don't need a lot of sleep so my
sleep results shows that
i only need less than seven hours of
sleep and that is true as well
some people might need more than nine
hours of sleep so
i think it's really interesting and it's
a very fresh insight for me as well so
i don't need more than seven hours which
is great
i'm a deep sleeper which is so true once
i'm asleep
seriously man good luck trying to wake
me up
so that's something really interesting
that i discovered in my result as well
okay we are at the end of our session
okay thank you so much champing
i really appreciate your time being here
and for sharing your knowledge
and um and also for helping our viewers
out
thank you so much okay thank you for
having me yeah any kind of words
uh i would say you know uh it's really
important that you take charge of the
health so you know
just doing the the dna testing or having
joiner tell you what to do it's not
enough it's really
based on you right you have to take the
initiative and you have to want this
really much
yeah so the the test and um you know
fitness influencers like joanna who
share so many useful tips it's really
important
but we have to be the ones who make use
of the knowledge from the
testing correct correct yeah so um i
think that's so true i mean i've been
sharing a lot of information on my
youtube channel
but it doesn't mean you should take my
word for it okay you need to
know how to adapt it according to your
body type exactly again thank you so
much champing for joining us thank you
thanks so much bye everyone bye chanting
all right i am excited
you guys are commenting non-stop
and again thanks for all the questions
for those of you whose
questions i didn't get to answer do
leave it on my youtube channel and i
will get back to you okay
and this is the time drum roll
we have been waiting for who are our
five
lucky winners okay again here's the
thing
you have to tune in right till the end
of
this live stream okay so i will be
announcing
our five lucky winners right at this
moment
and if i say your name i want you to
leave a comment
right now in the chat section
with the text one test one
lifetime okay if i mention you as one of
the lucky winners
do comment one test one
lifetime all right okay so
the first winner is
melvin wong be sure to comment right now
one test one lifetime the second winner
is janae janilla
okay j-e-n-e-l-y-n-a-g-d-a
be sure to comment one test one lifetime
and stay stay on the chat don't go off
yet the third winner is evgel
santos a-v-e-g-a-l-e
santos all right one test one lifetime
comment
two more winners two more winners the
next
winner chloe garcia well done
and who is our final winner
guys i wish i can give you all these
tests right now
okay the final winner is
okay just the letter k okay
so congratulations again to our five
lucky winners for winning this
what i want you to do to claim your
prize is
to drop me a direct message on my
instagram
page okay for those of you who haven't
followed me on the instagram
be sure to follow me on my ig page at
joannason official
go onto my ig page right now send me a
message and say that you are
the winner from our circle dna live
stream
chat for those of you who didn't win
don't worry okay
again you can still get lots of discount
if you were to purchase it today so go
on to circle dna.com and
use the promo code joanna you will get
35 off if you were to purchase one kid
two to three kids for 40 off and if you
purchase more than four kids
you will get 50 off so
get your family and friends to join in
and
do this test together because this test
will really
really help you not just in your health
and fitness journey
but but for you to also better plan your
future
and i've enjoyed today's session i think
it's been an amazing chat
amazing um chance for me to interact
with all of you
thank you so much again for joining me
again
any questions which i've missed and if
you really
are dying for me to answer them do leave
them in the comments
below alright and don't forget i will
see you in my next
youtube video this live stream is
brought to you by
circle dna now